GUS CLASS: Thank you, guys,
for coming out for our
presentation.
We're going to be talking
about best
practices for Google+.
Now this is Joanna Smith.
And I'm Gus Class.
And we're Developer Programs
Engineers on Google+.
For the past couple of months
we've been traveling around,
and talking with people who are
looking at doing Google+
Sign-In integrations.
We've learned a lot about what
works really well, and what
does not work so well.
But the most important thing
that we're going to try to
pass through today is what makes
an amazing integration
differentiated from a
basic integration.
So Joanna?
JOANNA SMITH: Exactly.
So the first thing
we want to do is
establish what is amazing.
And the easiest way I can think
to do this is to show
you a live example from one of
our partners here at I/O.
So Jolicloud is pretty cool.
They take all of their content,
be it personal or
social, and they aggregate into
a single user interface
for you to see.
But what makes them amazing, as
far as partners go, is the
fact that they do something
called dynamic scoping, where
they are letting users take
control of their sign-in
process from the
very beginning.
It can be really overwhelming
for some users, if they are
presented with a consent
dialogue with a lot of scopes,
because it's basically asking
for this permission and this
permission and this
permission.
And if you don't understand why
all of those permissions
are being requested, you might
get a little nervous about
granting access to this app.
And you might decide
not to do it.
Jolicloud decided to
make it better.
So what they do is you first
click on the button.
And then they bring up all of
the Google services that they
are offering.
And you're able to indicate
which Google
services you care about.
So for example, if I don't have
a YouTube account, if I
don't upload content or videos,
I'm going to be really
concerned about why somebody
wants access
to my YouTube activity.
So I am going to tell Jolicloud
that I'm not
interested in YouTube and
just the other things.
And then, when I click this red
button again, I'm going to
be presented with a Google
consent dialogue that only has
the scopes that I
have expressed
an interest in already.
And this is what we're
talking about.
When really going above and
beyond as far as the
integration is concerned,
cater your
experience to the user.
And let the user have control
over what they are doing, so
that you can customize
for them.
So we have a lot of really cool
tips and tricks today for
how to really make your
apps stand out.
But first, let's take our
roadmap, so that you
understand why you're here
and why you want to
stay in your seat.
GUS CLASS: So we've
broken up our
presentation into three pieces.
The first is going to be
about Google+ Sign-In.
And we're going to talk about
how you can use Sign-In to
take those people who visit your
site, and turn them into
users of your site.
Next, we're going to talk about
personalization, which
is taking those people who are
already on your site, getting
them integrated into your
site, and giving them an
experience that makes them
want to engage more.
And then, finally, we're going
to talk about how sharing can
turn those users who are already
engaged on your site
into people who will grow your
site into something bigger.
So Joanna is going to
start about Sign-In.
JOANNA SMITH: So the very first
thing you want to do is
you want to get your Google+
Sign-In Button perfect,
because this is how you're going
to really open a gateway
to your users.
You need them to sign in.
You need to meet them,
to know who they are.
You need to convince them to
click on that button because,
if you can get anybody who comes
to your app to click
Sign-In, they stop being
a visitor, and
they turn into a user.
One of the worst things for a
developer is having tons of
visitors, because you don't know
who they are, or how to
really engage them or keep
them on your site.
But once you have users, you can
customize the content and
really surface what's
interesting to them.
So the very first step in
getting somebody to click on
your button, it might seem
kind of obvious, but it's
making your button available.
This means having it
in a lot of places.
It's pretty apparent to most
developers to have their
button on the landing page.
Somebody arrives at the app.
They sign in.
And then they get to go.
It is less apparent to put a
Sign-In button next to a piece
of content, let's say, a video
or an article or a single
[? mean ?] even.
But honestly, this is
the entry point for
most of your users.
They're going to follow a link
or some content that has
already been shared.
That's where they're
going to come in.
This is also where
they're engaged.
This is where they're going
to have something to say.
So having a Sign-In button right
there waiting for them
is a really important tool.
One way you can do this is
having the Sign-In button as
part of your toolbar, or behind
a menu so that it
follows your user throughout
their entire app experience.
Another way is to try our small
Sign-In button, like the
favicon, so it's there waiting
for them when they decide that
they have something to say.
Because if you can get them to
engage in that conversation,
you're really going to improve
your entire app community.
And that's what we're
going for when
we talk about amazing.
So once you've figured out where
you want to put your
button, you need to make sure
you have the right look and
feel of it.
And part of this comes from
the customization process.
Gus?
GUS CLASS: Mm-hm.
So let's remember that the
Sign-In button is there
because you want to get users
to sign in to your site.
It's pretty evident.
But what Google has done is they
provided a lot of things
that make it easier for you
to get users on your site.
We have localized the button
to 60 different languages.
We give you multiple sizes.
And we also offer the button
in two colors.
A lot of people have asked in
our integrations, why do you
offer the red button and why do
you offer the white button,
when the Google+ button on
the Google site is red?
And so the reason that we offer
the white button is so
that you can have contrast
if your site has a red
background.
So going back to that, we want
that button to be familiar for
users when they reach
your site.
And so, in this way, we
recommend that you maintain
the Google+ branding on the
button, and that you also
ensure that your button has
contrast so that users can
easily see it.
Now when you customize the
button, as you can see Fancy
has done here, you want to make
sure that you maintain
that contrast, that you also
make sure that the button is
familiar for users who reach
your site, and that it matches
really well with what
you're doing.
So this is one of the best
practices that we've seen very
few people do, but that,
when it's done
well, it works amazingly.
So let's take a look at how
you can handle errors.
So you've probably seen this
line of code here before.
This is a very conventional
sign-in callback.
Now the two conditions that are
the most basic conditions
that you'll see are this top
one, which is when you get an
access token from the
sign-in callback.
And this is just your
success condition.
You know that the user has
successfully signed in.
And then the next is this
immediate failed.
So this is what happens
when the user has
not signed in before.
And then the sign-in callback
gets triggered when the user
automatically tries
to get signed in.
So what Joanna is going to show
you now is how you can go
a little bit beyond that, and do
something to differentiate
your site from other
integrations.
JOANNA SMITH: Exactly.
So as Gus pointed out, the
first two are very normal
prolific use cases.
But this second error code,
this one that says
access-denied, this is your
chance to be amazing.
So what this means is it means
that somebody came to your app
or your site, clicked on
Sign-In, and then hit Cancel.
And as a developer, I
imagine you want to
know why they're canceling.
What is it about your sign-in
experience that is not engaging?
And this is actually your moment
to ask your users,
essentially, right?
So a sign-in callback is a
beautiful thing, because it
triggers immediately after
somebody takes an action after
clicking that red button.
It is your moment to respond
to a user action.
And if that error code is
access_denied, that means
somebody canceled,
which means your
response could be a prompt.
It could remind a user of all
of the really cool features
that you have available to
signed-in users only.
Or perhaps you ask for a lot of
scopes, and this makes your
users uncomfortable.
You could explain your
scopes here.
You could have a prompt that
says, hey, we noticed you
didn't finish signing in.
We'd like to remind you that, if
you grant us permission to
your Google drive files, we'll
be able to do this, this and
this for you.
That's really simple.
And it's really easy
for you to do.
And then you can take it a step
further by having another
Sign-In button where you have a
conversation with this user,
so they can see why they
want to sign in.
And they can click
it right there.
They don't have to go back.
They don't have to start over.
They can just continue signing
in with your process.
And this is perfect for a
developer, because you want to
be able to engage your users.
You need them to sign in so that
you can learn about who
they are, and so that you
can begin to personalize
your app for them.
If you can really customize the
content for a user, you're
going to be able to turn them
into a contributor.
Everybody knows those users who
kind of show up, see if
anything's new, and
then leave.
But if there aren't any
notifications maybe waiting
for them, if none of their
social contacts have done
anything within your app, you
want to show them some other
content that's really
engaging.
Can you hear me?
Can you hear me now?
GUS CLASS: Yes.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
So you want to show them some
content that they're
interested in so that they
want to continue to
stay on your app.
And what you want to do is you
want to turn them into a
contributor.
You want them to start joining
the conversation, leaving
behind a comment, maybe adding
their own content to the
entire community.
That's what you really
want from a user.
That's how you're going to be
able to drive engagement and
increase the minutes spent
in your app every day.
So the first step of this is
greeting the user, making them
identify as a piece, as a
component of your app
experience.
And you can do this in
that same callback.
In the sign-in callback, on the
success condition, if you
make a people.get API call,
you're going to get their name
and their profile image.
And this is the first step
to greeting them.
You know that you're accustomed
to seeing a profile
image in the top toolbar.
And the reason is because this
is a powerful statement that
says, hey, you are
a part of my app.
Remember that you're
signed in.
Remember that what you do here
it contributes to your profile
and your experience.
But you can also take
it a step further.
SkillPages is a site where
people can go to list their
job skills and make contacts
so they can find a new
position, which means that the
most important thing on a
SkillPages user is
their profile.
So they want to keep working
on it, making it perfect.
And what they can do here
is Gus signs in,
and it's, hey, Gus.
We missed you.
Here are some things for you.
They greet Gus in a
large greeting.
They remind him of pieces of
his profile, like what he's
already connected his profile
to, and also where his
location is.
And then they show him
interesting content that they
think is already relevant
to him.
So he already has things to
click on, places to go.
And he is encouraged to remain
in the app for longer than he
would have if he'd just
logged in, saw no new
messages and left.
And this is what we're talking
about with reflecting the user
back, really making them
feel like they are a
component of your app.
But people.get is more than
a name and an image.
Gus, do you want to talk
about the rest?
GUS CLASS: Absolutely.
So what SkillPages did in their
integration is they
didn't stop at just
the profile.
They went and they realized
that this user has already
provided Google with lots of
this information that's
relevant to our site.
And so what they do is they pull
in your work history, and
they pull in your educational
history, to give you those
first couple of steps of
creating your profile.
Now imagine what an impact this
has on this website that
needs you to fill out all
this information.
All of a sudden, you no longer
have to say, oh, I remember
that I worked at Spam Arrest,
or I remember this and that
from my work history.
And the users also don't even
have to fill that out to start
making the connections that
are relevant for this.
And you would think that this
is a whole bunch of work.
But if we actually look at an
example of how this code
works, it's that same callback
that you've seen before.
So it's that plus.people.get.
And in this example here, what
I've done is I filtered it
down to just the organizations
that that user is part of.
And once you have those
organizations, you can
enumerate them by whether or
not they're educational
history, or whether or not
they're work history.
But it doesn't stop there.
If you want to have a really
amazing integration, you can
go beyond that, because there's
information that users
are providing you about
themselves already.
If you want to be really clever,
you can notice inside
of my stream that I'm sharing
all this information, and
other people are sharing all
this information, and that
there's a conversation
going on.
And so if you're doing
a really intelligent
integration, if your software
has all sorts of powerful
features for interpreting this
kind of information and
building those connections, then
what you can do is you
can then go deeper into that
user's friends' streams.
Then you can create connections
with their users
by using that information.
Now here's how it's done.
If you look at the code up here,
there is, again, that
plus.people list where I'm
retrieving the people who that
user has made visible
to this application.
And then what I'm doing is
retrieving the activities that
are publicly shared by those
person's friends.
And so, in this way, you
can bring in additional
information, and make
those great
connections between people.
Now just getting this
information and personalizing
your site is the start.
The next thing that really
is important
is going to be sharing.
JOANNA SMITH: That's right.
Once you know who a user is
interested in, you can start
using those connections to
really grow your audience.
And what you want to do here is
you want to turn that user
who has become a contributor,
that user who is leaving
content and is an active member
of your community, you
want them to be an evangelist.
But you don't want to hire
them or train them.
All you have to do is convince
them to share.
Because if a user is talking
about what they're doing on
your app, they're talking
about your app.
And that's the best way
for you to grow.
Word of mouth has always been
the most powerful way to
really reach out to a new
audience, because if somebody
brings their connections into
the app, they're going to
remain in the app.
That's going to drive
engagement, because they're
already going to have contacts
and people to interact with.
And that's why social
is so powerful.
So if you want to really reach
these new people, the first
step is understanding why
Google+ is different, because
we have two different
types of sharing
available to you as a developer.
The first is our most active
from of sharing.
And that's an interactive
post.
And you've been hearing about
these and how great they are,
because you get to really
target people.
You can flash those
notifications across all of
Google with a message
behind it that means
something to a user.
Because users know
that these aren't
programmatically written.
They know that it came from a
friend who had control over
the verbiage and the people
that it shared with.
So when they see these
posts, they know
that they mean something.
And they know that that button
is interesting, that it's
going to go somewhere beyond
just an app landing page.
But the second form of sharing
is through app activities.
And these are programmatically
written to a profile, which
does make them a more passive
form of sharing.
But the reason app activities
are amazing is because you're
not writing to Google+ and
then calling it a day.
You are writing to Google.
And this has strong
implications, because Google
loves data.
And we like to surface that data
in really interesting and
meaningful ways.
So some of you probably noticed
a few weeks ago, at
TechCrunch Disrupt, we announced
a new feature where
we are surfacing app activities
in search.
And this is what you're going
for as a developer.
You want to be able to reach
the people that your user
knows and cares about.
And you also want to be able
to reach people that they
might not already have
a connection to.
You want to use your aggregate
data to really appeal to other
people, to show why your
app is above the rest.
And so you can take a moment, as
a developer, to think about
how to best take advantage for
your app of these different
types of sharing.
How to really use them to
achieve what you're trying to
achieve, to grow the metrics
that you care about.
And once you've figured out
how you want to share, you
want to make sure that there's
consistency, so that your
messaging is recognizable and
familiar to the people that
you're reaching out to.
And that starts with
schema markup.
Gus?
GUS CLASS: Yep.
So we've been talking about
schema with Google+
for a very long time.
This is because schema is very
useful for search engines.
Many of you guys might already
be putting in schema microdata
onto your sites for search
engine optimization.
And so, when you provide this
information, it makes it much
easier to parse that
data on your site.
Now, with sharing, we have a new
usage of that microdata.
What we do is we look when you
pass a URL for that page with
that microdata on it.
And we use that microdata
to populate the share
information.
So here's a story of two
different shares.
If you look at the one
on the left, this is
the interactive post.
This is a targeted share, one
that's meant to go to a
specific person or a specific
list of people.
And you'll notice, in this
interactive post, what I've
done is I've said, oh, please
come and vote for my picture,
or come and vote for
[? Aude's ?] picture.
And inside of this interactive
post, there's a picture,
there's a title, and then
there's a description.
And all of this is populated
from the actual page that the
target is on.
And so, when you do it like
this, you can also do
something very interesting.
You can also have
app activities.
So what happened is, when I
voted on that picture for
[? Aude's ?]
photo, this app activity was
written to my profile.
And you'll notice that the
information is consistent
across all of this.
So the title, the image
and the action--
well, not the action-- but the
title and the image and the
description are all consistent
across here.
And something else happens
when you use URLs.
When you click on the actual
relevant part there, then you
can be directed back
to the site.
And this is a way that users
can re-engage from your
content in a way that is
familiar with them, and a way
that the behavior is
what they expect.
So when you're writing app
activities, when you're
performing interactive shares,
make sure that you're using
schema on your target pages
to populate that data.
Now there's one more thing
I want to bring up here.
You'll notice these app
activities here.
They're listed with
different types.
So there's listened, there's
reviewed, and there's a number
of other ones that we've
provided now.
Now this is a great time to
start talking about choosing
the right app activities, and
choosing the right calls to
action for your shares.
Joanna?
JOANNA SMITH: Some of the most
important things about sharing
is making sure that your
sharing is meaningful.
If you're going to grow your
audience, you want to make
sure that the people that you're
reaching out to are
responsive to your verbiage,
and to the
words that you choose.
And this comes with some
difficulty, because we have so
many options for you.
For example, our call to action
label has over 100
verbs for you to choose
from for that button.
And some of them are
very similar.
Consider buy and purchase.
To most people, these
are synonyms.
And yet, we've noticed that
some people respond to
purchasing as if they bought
for somebody else.
You purchase a gift, but
you buy for yourself.
And that's a small nuance
that's true for some
demographics.
And so this is a moment when,
as a developer, you want to
find the words that really
appeal to your user base, so
that when that button appears,
the people that are going to
want to be involved in your app
are going to click on it.
And this is also true for app
activity types for that first
word you see in an app activity,
because most people
like to use the ad activity,
which is sort of a catch-all.
It's user added this
content to my app.
And that's true for so many
instances, which makes it very
valuable to use.
But the more specific you can
be for Google, the more that
we can do with your data, and
the better we'll know how to
surface it to the right people
at the right time.
And so, when you're trying to be
specific and you're trying
to choose, again, it's
that nuancing.
And a really good example we
had with two of our launch
partners are TuneIn
and Shazam.
They're both music discovery
services.
It's a way for you to find music
and understand it and
learn about it.
But TuneIn went with a listen
activity, because that's truly
what its users are doing.
They are finding a radio station
anywhere in the globe
and listening to it.
And it can have social because,
for example, my
sister and I can listen to the
same radio station we grew up
with our whole lives, even
though neither one of us lives
in our hometown any more.
And that's a really good
bonding moment.
But it's still a listening
activity.
Whereas, Shazam decided to go
with more of the discovery
approach, because when you are
ready to use the Shazam app,
it's because you're out and you
hear a song, and you're
trying to remember what the
title is or who the artist is.
And you really want to be able
to learn more about that song
or that genre.
And so that's why it's a
discover activity, because
it's not just listening.
There's more to it.
And the different users that
these two apps are trying to
reach are going to respond to
the different words better.
And that's why you can really
take some time, as a
developer, to think about what
metrics you're really
interested in or what
demographics you're really
trying to reach out to or grow
to, and find the words that
are really going to
work for them.
And one thing that works
so well for this is
experimenting.
Our Google+ Platform Insights
give you a lot of data,
especially regarding
interactive posts.
So if you want to use different
verbs at different
times, maybe do some A and B
testing, you're going to be
able to see how responsive users
are to the different
words, and especially using
different verbs at different
points in your app.
The different activities that
users can do can trigger
different interactive shares.
And this is what's so valuable
about sharing, because it is
so targeting.
It's so diverse.
And that's what you
want to work for.
But all of this doesn't really
mean anything, if you can't
target the right people, if
you can't reach out to the
people that you are the
most interested in.
And that's the next tip
we have for you.
GUS CLASS: So if you look at
this code here, you can see
that here is a conventional
interactive post.
And then I've done something
different.
But I'll get to that
in just a second.
Now, when you create an
interactive post, there's this
experience where you
can create a good
experience for the user.
That interactive post renders.
And then they have a nice,
well-targeted call to action
so that when that post appears
in their stream, that users
know what they're going to
expect when they reach the
other side of that post.
Now you can do something
better than that.
What you can do is you can take
recipients and you can
pre-fill recipients
into that post.
And when you do this, something
very important happens.
Each of those recipients will
receive a notification across
Google, when they're in their
Gmail, when they're on their
Google+ account, when they're
in their calendar.
Those users will have that
notification there waiting for
them telling them, this person
want you to do something.
And that something that
they do goes directly
back onto your site.
And this allows your
site to grow more.
And you get that viral growth
pattern that happens when
people share to specific
people.
And because it's coming from a
specific person to another
specific person, you receive
that social proof that Gus
wants Joanna to share, or Gus
wants Joanna to do this.
And so let's look at this
code right here.
And I'm going to show you how
you can pre-fill those
recipients so that those
notifications are sent.
The first example that we have
here on the left is this long
string of numbers.
Now this long string of numbers
represents a Google ID.
So you can retrieve this Google
ID from an API query
against Google+ to
a list of people.
And to get this better
experience, what you can do is
you can order by best.
And the way that order by best
works is, when that list of
people comes back from Google,
Google has performed an
affinity calculation.
They determined who the people
who are the closest to this
current user.
And what that is it's a signal
to who the best people are to
target this post to.
And so, if you're targeting
these posts, use order by best
in order to determine the right
people to share with.
And we've also done something
else here where we've put in
someone by email, in this case
just a throw-away email that
I've given for this
conference.
And so you can also target
users by email.
And those users will also
receive notifications.
Now this is all great.
You can create this
well-targeted post.
And you can use signals from
Google, which Google pulls in
from what those users are doing
on Google+ and in Gmail
and so forth.
But you can do something
even greater.
You can create this amazing
experience for users by
performing calculations based
upon your own information that
you have about your own users.
And you can do things like
create interactions between
your users by bringing them to
and from the Google+ stream
with these targeted
interactive posts.
And this is really what
differentiates a basic
integration from one that just
really stands out to us.
And it's always exciting for
users to see that your site is
created in such a way that their
interactions are made
much easier.
So we're going to give you one
more tip about interactive
posts, before moving on.
JOANNA SMITH: So anyone who was
at Jonathan Barry's talk
yesterday with the introduction
to Google+
Sign-In probably heard something
cool, which is that
the interactive post is
a Sign-In button.
But I want to take a
moment to delve a
little deeper into this.
The interactive post is
a Sign-In button.
That's a really cool feature,
because it means that every
single share on your app could
potentially result in a
signed-in user.
And that's what you're really
going for, if your key metric
is to get more signed-in users
or to really increase
engagement, because you want
to know who they are.
You want to understand
your users.
But there's one drawback to this
feature, which is that
the interactive post sign-in
option does not support the
Overthere install consent
dialogue.
And if you're main metric is
driving Android app installs,
if that's what you're really
focused on this month or this
year, this is not the
feature for you.
And so one thing that we
recommend is that you hide the
share option.
Or perhaps you use our original
normal Share button,
until a user has signed in.
And then you can replace that
with the interactive post
sharing option.
And this way, you can channel
all of your sign-in traffic
through the Sign-In button, so
you can trigger that Overthere
install and really drive your
Android app installs.
But like I said, this is another
one of those moments
when you really want to think
about what your key metrics
are as a developer, so that you
can create the integration
that's really going to be right
for your company and for
you, as well as for
your users.
But no matter what you decide,
if you end up going with the
interactive post or if you just
have sign-in in multiple
places, you're going to want
to notice that several of
these parameters are the same.
These are the parameters that
determine the permissions that
your users are going
to grant you.
And if these ever fall out of
sync between any of your
sign-in options, you're going
to end up with a broken user
experience.
You're going to have users who
have granted different levels
of permissions, depending
on whatever
these parameters were.
And that's not amazing.
And so one thing that you really
want to do is you want
to be programmatically filling
all of your sign-in things so
that when you change something,
if you need to add
an additional app activity type,
or if you want to expand
to start using Google Drive,
for example, you want to be
able to change the scopes
everywhere with a single
change in one place, so that
you never fall out of sync
with yourself.
So that's actually all of the
tips that we had for you today
in this half hour.
But we have lots more.
And if you want to
ask us questions,
we're happy to help.
They can be specific
or abstract.
The other thing that we
recommend is we have a lot of
really cool talks going on this
year at I/O. So if you
missed Jonathan Barry's talk
yesterday, but you really want
to know more about each feature,
I recommend watching
the video as soon
as it goes up.
And if you're interested in more
mobile tips and tricks,
we have an entire session in
the Android track dedicated
just to Google+ Sign-In
on Android.
Or you can always check out
Ian Barber's talk on iOS
integration, because the--
I meant Silvano's talk
on iOS integration--
because these are the ways you
can really learn about the
mobile-specific things.
And then, of course, we're
going to take your
questions right now.
We have two mics you
can line up at.
But before we take those,
we're just going
to sum things up.
GUS CLASS: So in short, what we
really wanted to impart on
you guys is that, when you
create an amazing integration,
it's just a little different
from the basics.
Think about the ways that you
can really differentiate and
make the most of all of
the tools that we're
offering with Sign-In.
And when you do this in a really
good way, you get the
most out of these features.
You get more users
on your site.
You end up getting more engaged
users, because these
users are interacting with
each other more.
And they have more filled
out profiles.
And they're finding more
people, making more
connections.
And then they're also drawing
more people to your site.
They're encouraging growth.
And they're making your site
into a better experience, into
something better for everyone.
And one thing that we're always
trying to do is find
more things that people are
doing really creative uses of
the APIs for partnerships
that we create.
So if you guys are out there and
you've got a site, and you
guys are thinking you're doing
something fantastic, or
there's something fantastic that
you want to do, but we
just aren't offering that little
piece that you need to
be able to do it, find
us on Google+.
Or reach out to us on the
Google+ Stream or in our
communities, and let us know
what you're thinking about.
We always try to be
very responsive to
what developers want.
And we also are always eager
to work with people who are
doing magnificent things.
So that's all we have.
Amaze us, guys.
We're ready for questions.
Again, please just come
to the aisle and ask
them from the mics.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: In your last point,
you mentioned about being able
to change scopes.
Can you explain more on that?
Do you prefer having those
scopes defined?
I'm developing the Google+
Sign-In for Android.
And generally, we basically
define the scopes upfront when
we instantiate the +client.
But you mentioned about--
JOANNA SMITH: So what I meant
is if your app has largely
been targeted toward one, just
toward + and you're later
expanding to something else,
it's going to be a really
massive change.
So you're going to change
it in the +client.
But it's going to force
re-granting permissions for a
lot of your users.
So it'd be a big change.
But if you ever did that, you
would want to make sure that
it would change everywhere,
right?
AUDIENCE: OK.
OK.
JOANNA SMITH: It's not
like a daily change.
No.
AUDIENCE: Right.
But you wouldn't suggest
like, let's say you
already signed in.
And then, while the user is
interacting with their app--
oh, by the way, I
need this code.
JOANNA SMITH: To
sign-in again.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: You wouldn't want
an experience where users
have to sign in and then somehow
re-grant permissions,
which is why we have that
ability to have multiple
scopes in a single string.
It's this separated string, so
that you can get all of the
permissions in one
consent dialog.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JOANNA SMITH: And that's
what's so good.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Yeah.
Thank you.
GUS CLASS: And so yeah, I'll
make one more comment there.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
GUS CLASS: What Jolicloud is
doing is that, when the user
signs in, there's a button
on the bottom.
Technically speaking, it's
a fake Sign-In button.
AUDIENCE: Right.
GUS CLASS: When they click
it, it draws up a pop-up.
And then they have this
selector, so you just click on
check boxes.
And then the scopes field that
is passed into the Sign-In
button that renders
on the bottom
is dynamically populated.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Right.
GUS CLASS: I mean, it's a very
small snippet of code that you
would have to write in
order to do that.
JOANNA SMITH: It just appends a
string, depending on what's
been checked.
GUS CLASS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So basically, the user would
basically select
what he or she wants.
And then, depending
on what's the
selection, that's the scope.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah.
So it's honestly just a
dynamically appended string.
AUDIENCE: Right.
JOANNA SMITH: And then that gets
passed in the OAuth call.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
GUS CLASS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Going back to
people.get, and importing
people's personal information
that already exists as part of
the Google profile, how would
you suggest dealing with, I
guess you would call it the
creepy factor, where people
see their information on
whatever service they happen
to sign in, to and don't
understand where it came from
and how it got there, even if
they have already provided
that information elsewhere?
Because I've definitely heard
a lot of complaints, even
people talking about
Google Services.
GUS CLASS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And they don't
understand how that
information got where it got.
And it bothers them.
GUS CLASS: So the activities
read API, which is the way
that you can read people's data,
is restricted only to
public data.
And this is to protect the
users, and to maintain that
expectation that their data is
private and safe within the
social network that we have.
JOANNA SMITH: But more
specifically, I think it's
what you're getting at, if
you're using the people.get
call and you're trying to pull
in their work experience and
stuff, it's granted in the
response, only if it's been
made available on the stream.
So if they've hidden it there,
it won't come to you.
So there will never
be a surprise.
But one thing you could do, if
you are worried about that
creepy factor, because I
understand what you mean, is
there's two things that
I can see working.
You could have a favicon.
Like, oh, you got
this from G+.
Or you could try the
"confirm" dialogue.
Hey, we've pulled
your profile.
We see that you worked
here, here and here.
Is this true?
And then let them
edit it, right?
Because if they feel like
they've had some sort of
control, they'll probably feel
more ownership over it, as
opposed to creepiness.
GUS CLASS: And a final note.
When you're pulling this data,
there is a developer policy
that, once that user explicitly
disconnects their
account, that the data
should be deleted.
So in doing this, we do
try to build that
trust for the users.
And we hope that, over time,
that that will show through
with our services.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This question is
about sharing.
GUS CLASS: Sorry.
Say that again?
AUDIENCE: The question
is about sharing.
GUS CLASS: Oh, sure, yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So when a user clicks on Share
button, does the application
get information about
user, like user ID?
JOANNA SMITH: When somebody
clicks the Share button?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JOANNA SMITH: So that Share
button is a Google owned,
Google created button.
So if they aren't signed
in to your app?
Is that your use case?
Like they aren't signed in, but
they're trying to share?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: So in that
instance, when somebody's not
signed in to you, but they are
signed in to their browser or
into their phone, then we're
going to know that, because
we're Google and we know when
somebody's signed in to the
browser, for example, like
signed in to Chrome.
And so, when they go to
share, we'll pull
that information in.
Or if they're not signed in at
all or if we don't know, then
it'll pull in a sign-up
dialogue first.
And they can sign in,
and then they can
continue with the share.
AUDIENCE: So the callback
response gives the user ID,
something like that, right?
GUS CLASS: For interactive
lists.
AUDIENCE: After clicking
on the Share button.
Let's say you are signed in.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh.
So you're trying to say for
callback for a share?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: So we
don't currently
have our own callback.
And if you're creating one, you
would want to have it so
that they signed in first, so
that you would already have
information about them.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So I want to encourage users to
share with something then.
So I want to reward them with
points or anything, like in a
loyalty program.
So I want a callback
response when they
click on Share button.
GUS CLASS: So in those cases,
there is no first party
offering that we have that
will allow you to detect
whether or not that
user shares.
Is that what you're asking?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh.
So OK, I don't really know quite
what you're getting at.
But one thing I can say is, if
you want to come to our booth
right after this, we'll
both be there.
And we can try to figure
out your question
a little bit better.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
Thank you.
JOANNA SMITH: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
JOANNA SMITH: Thanks.
GUS CLASS: Yep.
JOANNA SMITH: I didn't
know that I did that.
Does anyone else have
any questions?
[LAUGHTER]
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
Well, thank you.
GUS CLASS: All right.
Well, a very big thanks,
you guys.
[APPLAUSE]